the crisis at FIFA tomorrow's
presidential election will still be
going ahead and set latter looks likely
to survivor joining me now is Martin
Lipton deputy head of sports content at
the Sun and we're going to talk through
the voting process tomorrow and a lot of
people are going to find it fascinating
that there are only two candidates of
course there's the incumbent president
sepp blatter there's also in this man
Prince Ali why is he his only opponent
in tomorrow's race well they were were
originally five other candidates two of
those didn't make the ballot paper one
with Siobhan champ Annja who was a
former secretary-general at FIFA a close
aide of Blatter at one stage who was
part of a it was basically tossed out in
a in a cabal in 2010 at the world cup in
south africa and then david genola also
didn't make the nomination there were
two who did the dutchman van park who
was the head of the dash FA and also
luis figo the former portuguese play
until last week all three of all of the
three candidates to oppose better word
on the on on on the putt on the
nomination paper on the ballot paper but
then two of them decided to step down as
everyone there was a view within UEFA
that the only way they could win will be
to unite behind a common candidate one
candidate and they chose Finn salad
because he isn't European basically
because he represents asian football
potential there could be some flake off
from the asian asian vote in his favor
and that's the thinking behind this so
the other candidates pulled out to give
prince ali the best chance let's talk
through this voting process 209 FIFA
members how does it go basically the
first round you have to get two-thirds
majority so if all 209 vote Blatter or
Prince area had to win on the first
ballot need 140 votes if there's a
second vote it's just a simple majority
it certainly would be expectation of
latter they would win quite comfortably
in the first round if it went to a
second round that would be a major issue
for Blatter because it was show they
didn't have the extent of support which
he believes he has even at this stage
after all that's gone on over the last
few days well member nations tend to
vote in blocks don't they and these are
the kind of numbers up for grabs Africa
jumps out 54 votes the most votes there
there a real power play Martin yeah it's
the 6th Confederation of each other's
basically the continents
and Blatter has always been very strong
in Africa because he's the protégé of
joão havelange the previous FIFA
president who basically became president
because he usurped Stanley Mouse by
getting the support of the smaller
nations by offering them more plated in
the world cup of previously there was
only one African team suddenly there's
there were two three four and now five
the same for Asia even Oceania now have
got a chance of a half place a play-off
place guarantee for a place of the world
cup its largesse and the bit as a rule
many of the nature of the Confederations
do vote in blocks and two of the biggest
blocks always tend to go for set Blatter
Asia and Africa very much so there's
been a slight splitting Asia in the past
when the Korean dr. Chung was was head
of the career in FA and the Koreans and
Japanese were anti Blatter but he had
the support of of the Middle East very
much people like me mohammed bin her man
and others in the Middle East Africa or
whether it's a hatch who's ahead of
Africa stood against him in 2002 has
been very much returned to the fold and
even in two thousand show with an
African candidate that I've got 40 of
this 50 votes in Africa in comparison
Prince Ali has got the backing of Europe
52 roads but you might you think he
might not even get all of those I will
be amazing if he gets more than 35
significant European nations I suspect
will vote for Blatter France have
already said they will spain I think
we'll Iceland and Norway and of course
let's think about Russia 2018 the one
thing that would date in danger Russia
hosting the world cup will be of Blatter
were to lose his his position we've had
bad Emir Putin talking about that
already about this whole FB I think
being a plot to stop Vash again the 2018
world cup the Russian sports minister is
on the FIFA let's go he's going to vote
for Blatter and the Russian satellite
nations may well do as well I Kate
Martin we have to leave it there that
vote going ahead as planned tomorrow and
it looks like a foregone conclusion that
set Blatter will win